et bien le ministre de l'intérieur a été
interrogé par l'un de vos collègues les
républicains notamment sur les
propositions de loi qui sont depuis ce
week-end par les républicains pour mieux
réguler l'immigration il y a une
proposition de loi constitutionnelle qui
propose de déroger à certains traités
internationaux à certains engagements
européens Charles Darmanin a l'air
contre il a parlé cet après-midi de
frexit migratoire vous reprenez cette
expression écoutez moi je trouve
pertinent et positif que les
républicains expriment leur position
c'est bien parce que tout le monde parle
de ces sujets mais on voit assez peu de
propositions écrites donc il va y avoir
une proposition écrite nous nous allons
faire nos propositions également ils
seront différentes à l'évidence nous
sommes européens et nous sommes très
attentifs au cadre européen la
Constitution on peut la modifier mais ça
prend du temps il faut les trois
cinquième je vous rappelle donc on va
essayer de trouver des solutions et des
propositions qui soient plus faisable et
plus rapidement quels seront les grandes
lignes des propositions centristes sur
les migration oh bah il y a une partie
qui reprend ce qui a déjà été voté je
vous rappelle qu'un texte a été voté par
la commission des lois et c'est sûrement
je n'en sais rien mais à partir de ce
texte que les discussions pourront
peut-être reprendre dans quelques
semaines vous pensez que vous trouverez
un accord avec les sénateurs de la
républicains notamment sur le réseau il
y a pas de raison on peut être on fait
ça tous les jours ici donc on pourra
trouver des compromis en tous les cas je
l'espère
[Musique]